ん
me
入道いいいい
私はまあ約30年にわたって経営コンサルタントあるいは企業アドバイザー
仕事をしてきました
まあ30年ということですからちょうど最初の15例は未受精
後半の15年まさに21世紀
ということなんですけども今日話したいテーマ
重要なことはこの20世紀の後半そしてこの21世紀の前半にかけて大きな変化の
で
その変化に対して
特に私の専門は企業なんですが企業の組織あるいは個人というのは
なぜ簡単に対応することはできないのかなぜ変化は難しいのかということで
チェーンジ変化をテーマに少しお話をしたいというふうに思います
最初に今起きたその
世界の経済構造あるいは社会の構造
結果として企業の経営環境どう変化したのかと
何が変化したのだということを少しお話をしたいというふうに思います
3つ書いてあります1個目グローバライゼーション見込めマーケットででしょう
3個目デジタライゼーション
重要なことはまあこの後ご説明しますけれどもこの3つの大きな変化というのが同時
並行的にほぼ20世紀の最後
それこそ85年以降起きたということです
これが服帽子合わさったことによって
非常に巨大な変革が今進行しているということです
まず1点目のグローバライゼーションですけれども象徴的にはこれは1989年の確か
11月国のか
マーベル員の風の公開とっていうのがありましたその結果戦後長く日本を含む正に指令
を急い深刻5億人の経済クラブ
これ安定した先進国経済というのがまさにグローバル経済
ほとんどすべてだったわけです
そこに一気に20億そして40億という新たな市場が変わった
その市場というのは均質な市場ではなくて非常に変化の激しいダイナミックな市場が何
時
また新たな強豪プレイヤーも台頭した当然企業の戦略そして企業の組織っていうのも
ok 機的な変化というのが要求された理由
から2番目のマーケティゼーションっていうのは要は資本市場の拡大です
これも急膨張しました今や1日の例えば為替取引額っていうのは多い時には5兆ドル
すなわち600松屋これは日本が1年間に活動した成果としての gdp を超える
数字が1日で取引されているここまで市場が巨大化したということです
したがってかつては金融というのは経済あるいは実体経済を支えるまあ血流であるとか
インフラの役割だったわけ
ところが今や金融経済が変動すると実体経済が降りません
すなわちいいので言えばシッポが胴体を振り回すような状況になってしまう
aa 10巻前から行けば結局金融の父が実体経済の地域に波及する
我々は最近リーマンショックっていうのを経験した場合ですけど
そうするとこれだけ変動がある機器が頻発する経済あるいは市場にどう対応するかと
いうことが大きなテーマになっています
それから市場という意味においては特に企業にとってみるとここ10年15年で重要に
なったのはやはり株式市場株式上の影響が非常に高まったあるいは株主価値型っていう
のが浸透してきたということです
私が駆け出しのコンサルとなった頃それこそ80年代の後半とか90年
株価を気にしてるとかか星勝経営を標榜しているような経営者というのはほとんどい
ませんでした
今株主なんか関係ないっていう発言を上場企業のトップがしたら大変なペナルティを
マーケットが抜ける
いうことでこうした株主価値経営というものが浸透してきたのもこの10年15年から
もう一つ資本市場のインパクトで大きいのは結局市場において企業の値段がつく授業の
値段が付くその結果
m an で用水事業や企業のば媒介ということが盛んに活発になったわけですこれも
カツ
しては
少なくとも日本においては市場等的な手段であったものが今日これはもう常套手段で
ありこれを指定する経営者もいいなんだ
当然それは事業の経営のあり方そして経営能力においても新たなチャレンジを突きつけ
たことも言うまでもありません
それから3つ目がデジタライゼーションでこれは説明する必要もないと思います
例えばパソコンが生まれたら80年代の半ば macintosh が出たが84年
マイクロソフトが windows を出したのは85年90年代になると
インターネットが台頭してきます
netscape が生まれたのは95年 google が google が勧請
したのは1990
18年そして2000年以降 imt 2000と言われるくらいですから3g の
ネットワークは居留守の世界が入ってきたの2000年以降
そしてソーシャルということで制すドックが創業したのが2004年
85年から今日までこの圧縮された期間の中においてデジタライゼーション
をインターネットやそれから it の技術の革新との劇的に進んだわけです
これも言うまでもなく企業経営のあり方や企業の組織の在り方はビジネスモデル大きな
変革を迫ったわけです
これだけ環境が変わったわけですから企業もそして我々個人も変化をしなければいけ
ないわけですけども
実際にはなかなか変革することが難しい
企業の場合葬式の場合変革できずに競争力を失っていくこういうフェイスも多いわけ
です
なぜ葬式の変化が難しいのか
まず1点目 brain ストップすなわち思考停止つまり変化を築くことがない
あるいは場合によっては変化を無視してしまうこういうことが特に組織においては
大きいます
典型的なパターンを言うと
成功体験
でこれは誰しもそうですが成功すればその成功を守りたくなる
企業においてもそうで成功してる事業があればそれにチャレンジしてくるものを
それに挑戦してくるものというのはできれば排除したいし
から過小評価をすることもよくあります例えば思い出すのは80年代日本の自動車会社
のトップは関空の自動車産業が日本の自動車産業にキャッチアップすることはない
だろうと言ってましたあるいは90年代に通信会社のトップがインターネットが実用に
足るってことはないだろうとこういう発でもしてました
このようにやはり過小評価をする傾向っていうのはあるわけです
ここに組織が関与すると問題が深刻化します
例えば当然成功している事業のトップというのは
その会社の中で取り食べて前者のトッ
影響力のあるポジションにつくわけですそうするとその人の価値観成功体験っていうの
がその組織を支配するようになる
それがもしサラリーマン方の葬式完了形の組織をすると誰もその1上位者にチャレンジ
する人がいない
チャレンジしても報われないか
そうするとじつは外で変化を気がついていたとしてもそれを意思決定されたのかな
結局組織的に内向きになり思考停止になっ
こういう状況こういうことで私は多く遭遇しました
1個目は気づかない brain ストップに米がパスイベントですて変えてあります
けども
まあ直訳をすれば経路依存性
これは人も組織も同じですけども自分が学んだことを見つけた知識技術で問題を解決
する
当然そういうことになるわけです
ところが企業の場合はそれが問題になるのですこういうことわざがあります
あなたが持っている道具がー
カナヅチだとするとすべての問題が釘に見える
あなたが持っている道具方の自殺するとすべての問題は釘に見える
すなわちメカトロにかけていればやっぱりメカたので解決をしようとする春を避けて
いればハードの技術で解決するようです
ところがたとえばアップルが itunes と ipod で新しい音楽のサービス
の提供でてきたときにそうしたメカトロやハードに長けた
日本の電気メーターというのはほとんど対応することができなかった
これは+詭弁です要はスキルの欠落
こういう問題っていうのがやっぱり変化を築いたとしてもできないと言う
こういう問題に遭遇するわけです
3番目に変えたんなコンプレックスティまあ言ってみれば柵です
特に成功している授業であればあるほどそこにおいては利益共同体的な性格をいます
それは川上のサプライヤーから川下の流通販売まで含めて利益共同体になってくる
ソースと自社が大きくビジネスモデルを転換したい
でもそれは彼は神は彼は下の人たちにとってみると収益失ってしまうということになる
かもしれない
当然抵抗数
あるいはこちら側も配慮する結果的に調整コスト
調整の時間が膨大になって変化ができない気づいてスキルがあったとしても変化に
手間取るこういうことになります
業務も同様で成功している業務であればあるほどそこにおいては作り込まれたプロセス
がそこに新しい技術が出てきたとしてもその技術を自分だけは
プリエた場合全体最適が崩れてしまう
これがコンプレックス t のバナー
こうした brain ストップか過ぎ便利ですコンプレッサーいっていうのはどの
組織でもを受けるわけで変化に気が付かない
気づいたとしてもその能力がない能力があったとしても変わらない
いろんなはらがいろいろあるということです
じゃあどうすればいいのか
いうことなんですけどもいわゆるコインの裏材し簡単な答えを言えばプレイストップを
排除するためには常に考えるそしてを作ればいい
具体的にはよく言われる開かれた組織オープンの組織そっとの交流がある組織そして
より重要なことは社内の体制として車レンズ
そうした体質というのを社内に作っていくと
ジョブズが
アップルの企業体数
説明するときにアップではベストアイディア種類んと言ってます誰だ言った方が上位者
が入ったかじゃなくて
一番良いアイディアを出してそのアイデアを取っていくというこういう体質をつくった
それがアップの強さだというふうにジョブされています
こうした組織こうしたものを作れるかこうした風土
こうしたものを作れるかそれが大きなテーマになります
それからぱすーテンデンスを降伏するためにはそれは文字通り
新しいスキルを学習すればいいあるいは古いスキル wandering すればいい
しかしから実際にはなかなか難しいまあ京急立場でいけば首都を入れ替える事業をやり
入れ替えるこういうことをするということになるわけですけど大変に厳しい判断が求め
られる
それからコンプレックス t 柵を突破するというのはこれはもうそうした利害関係者
というものも巻き込んで
で強い意志を持って改革を進めていくしかないわけです
じゃあこれは誰がやるのかということになれば
言うまでもなくリーダーしリーダーの仕事だということになるわけです
変革を示しそうして変革を進めていくのはリーダーの仕事になるわけですが
今日リーダーシップくらい貴重な資源はない求められる資源はない人材はないと
それはもう企業の現場においても教育の現場においてもリーダー育成っていうのが
を最大のテーマになっているなぜかそれは変革の時代だか
じゃあリーダーシップやリーダーの大悟は何かといえばあえて言えばマネージャー
あるいはマネージメントということになりますここで言うマネージャーというのは決め
られた番組の中においてきちんと成果を出す
大変に重要な役割です
ただ今申し上げたように
変化の時代においてはこの枠組みを壊していくとこういう力が必要であってそれは
マネージャーの仕事ではなく
リーダーの仕事になるということです
今日は
テッド you 東京ということで東大に来てます
東京大学っていうのは紛れもなくあらゆる集をとっても日本のリーディング入りバーし
てやることは間違いないですし
アジアのリーディングにバーシティであり世界有数のリーディングにバーティー
じゃあリーディングリバース t の東京大学がリーダーうんだろう
赤美アカデミーの分野ではどうかと卑近な例でいけばノーベル所
プレゼント東京大学強いのか
あるいはビジネスの分野できたらビジネスアントル風なビジネスリーダー
プレゼンさあ高いのか必ずしもそうでもないということだと思います
考えてみれば東京大学は
優秀なマネージャーを大量に育成してくるということにおいては非常に大きな貢献をし
たわけです
ただいま突きつけられているのは大仕上げたように不足しているのはマネージャーでは
なくてリーダーです
成功している企業大きくなっている企業には大量のマネージャーがいます
だけどわずかなリーダーし海外いかにリーダーを育成するかということが求められて
いるということです
ただリーダーというのは当然個人です
ですから最後は個人の問題ということですでリーダーのあるいはリーダーシップ
こうしたものの支出であるとか要件というのはいろいろとも書かれていると思います
ビジョナリーであるコミュニケーションのスキルが高い
カリスマ性があるいろいろあると思います
その中でもし一つ最も大事なリーダーの失踪というふうに問われればこれは決断をする
力だと思います
決断というのは文字通り決めて断つ
こういう能力がリーダーに求められるんだと思います
ところが変革をするということは当然リスクを伴うわけです
で今うまくいっている授業を破壊するということになるかもせ
そういう意味においては決めて断つために必要な物は何かと
いうと最後にまあ皆さんのメッセージとして
申し上げたいのは苛烈
雪だということです皆さんの健闘を祈ります